excuse Matt Walsh in Ted who is Ted
anyway no I'm straight
is Matt Walsh in Elf oh the movie Elf
okay so I see what we're doing here we
are getting questions for me and for the
other Matt Walsh because there's a
there's a second Matt Walsh out there
actually and uh so I guess we're gonna
get some of his questions too
and you know something interesting has
happened because when I first came on
the scene the other Matt Walsh was like
the way more famous Matt Walsh and so if
you want to Google all the Matt Walsh
information was about that Matt Walsh
and now it's kind of flipped and I think
I've sort of uh
subsumed I've I've all I've I've
absorbed all the other Matt Walsh's
doesn't even sound right I just said I
was straight so